[Musica]
ciao ragazzi siamo su questo video lo
dobbiamo indovinare i personaggi loro
dell'altro
dobbiamo fare così eccolo che molto mi
fanno già male le gambe con alta cifre
false a ragazzi attivo verso l'alto a 60
punti di con il classico gioco nel
indovina chi dovevano scrivere un
personaggio attacca la testa
un altro è questo qualcun altro lo devi
indovinare non abbiamo più biglietti
spero che per indovinarlo la suddetta
persona deve fare una domanda alla quale
si può rispondere soltanto sì o no
esempio è maschio
se la risposta è sì la persona può
continuare a fare le domande sarà il
castello si possono però successiva fine
delle regole delle terre per
appiccicarsi le carte sulla testa a
seguire la presa di catena che nessuno
di noi si legge la prendo vino
lei che deve recare un altro nostro io
ci tenevo a dire una cosa di tutti i
nomi io ho scritto quello che aveva in
testa marco giusto perché si sappia e
vice versa attiva no no no non si
sarebbe voluto fare e io infine questo
che mi ha scritto marco quindi va beh
cominciamo famoso personaggio ci si
nel mondo esempio una personaggio
fittizio
no no sono famoso sono vivo che so se
non sono morto per le morti sono
nell'ambito cinematografico sea ray e
non sono un cartone quindi sintassi non
sei un campione
insomma un attore no no sono un
personaggio di qualcosa
si si avete la domanda mia genere
sprezzanti con la mela vicino a persona
[Musica]
però non sono italiano sì non sei
italiano si non sono italiano dei
videogiochi
vabbè non vuol dire il nome è che non
sono però personaggi dei videogiochi che
il gioco a marco mai giocato pete dye e
scrittori camera non c'è un maggiore
perché sono sempre esister si ok ok
anche monotono un essere di sesso
maschile
se si rimane a me non è appagato ma
tecnica di marina era incinta il prof
sono un essere sono tiziano no per
difendersi lo chiede quindi sono
fittizia nome inserito sono del mondo
del cinema
l'internet no non influenza è famosa in
italia
zaia e vivo si sono maschio insieme a
circa 80 sì sì sì io non so niente
a bristol zero dice oh ma lo sai che si
sono messi la nostra idea maturata a
bristol soprattutto propri salariale
chattiamo presta tra presto abbiamo il
servizio dal nostro inviato a cristo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
quindi
è stato quando suonati nome russo
maschio si ok però comunque sono ma non
essere che non sono il cantone sono
famoso per un film è una serie di file e
alternare i videogiochi che non aggrada
quindi tutto questo ma non l'hai mai
giocate impersonale super smash allora
sera è l'amica possano arrivare quanti
personaggio 68 68 assetto futuro di
burton i personaggi super smash bros
sono tanti ragazzi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
beh forse perché sto demolirla di kirby
magari montino ha costituito motivo le
ali alle analisti sì ma per caso mi sono
chiamato qualcuno ovunque ho portato un
messaggio che qualcuno si fa male come
fai perché ho passato delle note per
rimanere incinta sono il santissimo
arcangelo gabriele
[Musica]
[Applauso]
il culo ma ci sono non a ciccio merino 6
battute addirittura la guardavo quando
stavo mangiando 6 come gioielli
tormentoni fisiche altro uomo
io voglio fare una cosa ci vedo le
veline adesso i j
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma di una consiglio italiano che sono
entrambi dopo album ma è giusto così
la musica giovane si è si pratica dopo
il nevada e famoso sì ma che cos'è anche
le penne bic su un aereo e altri come
progetto si legge più o meno è un
edificio non ho capito male aveva ormai
però il david di michelangelo
l'altra
persone che di marco nome di male al
figlio di mamma e di questo di questo
sport a presto
allora hai detto tutte quante le cose
possibili di tutti i materiali e
possibili tra nella
giocata ad ora sembra della pietra a
detta dell'uomo è stata quindi seguita
in bronzo di riace dove ragazzi cosa si
parla internet ore di lanciarlo il
telecomando
dovresti più del 2 marche vicino alla
videocamera metti una cosa viva camera
dicendo beh ragazzi in modo nostro
carino perche i ragazzi al prossimo io
di lui lorenzo fa leggere
[Musica]